The joe rogan experience,
we're also paying for the sins of a lot
of other people.
Like for centuries,
let's,
you know,
white American men dominated everything
in this country.
And,
and like,
you know,
there's also a reality of a lot of
people were treated like garbage for a
long time and a lot of promises were
broken.
And there's a reality to that.
That's not excuse making,
it's not right.
It's a real thing.
And,
and then they say,
well,
you know why people have benefited from
that system even to,
so what's happening is in an effort to
balance the fucking playing field a
little bit,
a lot of us today are being treated
unfairly because the balancing act is
making things go so far.
Like I do understand that.
Like,
that's why I had a conversation after a
Tashas.
Uh,
uh,
and who did they get?
Oh,
Tracy's gay jokes.
And I had a couple of days from folks
who don't know,
Tracy Morgan did a joke about if his son
was gay,
he would stab them.
Yeah.
And everybody went crazy.
And I had a couple of gay comics on Rick
Chrome and Jim David and we talked about
this on this comedy special I did.
And uh,
the as Comedians,
I asked them how do they feel about the
imbalance in the language?
Like the fact that you get in trouble
for that now.
And Jim David said,
I'm okay with it.
And uh,
I'm like,
well how are you okay with there's a
comic?
And he goes,
cause it's not a level playing field.
Meaning what he thought was like in
life,
gay people had not treated as well.
So he didn't give a shit if,
if that guy got in a little bit more
trouble and I kind of,
I heard what he said,
they're like,
even though I don't want to get in
trouble for it,
in that sense he was right.
It's like,
you know,
we still have a big segment of our
country that can't get married and
they're treated like second class
citizens,
but yet we go around and tell other
countries had to live their lives were
so fully shit.
It makes me nuts.
Well,
I think there's a real legitimate
argument in the,
uh,
idea that until it balances out,
until everyone completely relaxes on
discrimination towards gays.
Like,
like there's no discrimination on
bachelors anymore.
You know,
like if a man is a 50 year old man,
he says,
I'm just not getting married again.
There's no discrimination or social pro.
He's not a social pariah.
But if he decides to marry a man than it
is like,
well what?
Well,
what is that and why is that not
eradicated from our culture yet?
Well,
once that is eradicated from our
culture,
then I shank people are going to be much
more likely to accept gay jokes much
more like,
because I keep hearing that gay jokes or
homophobic and I'm like,
guess what?
No,
they're not.
It's not homophobic at all.
It's a gay joke.
Just like jokes about straight sex
aren't Hetero volvic alright,
they're jokes about sex and there's,
there's,
there's jokes about everything and it's
really about context.
It's not about the subject matter and
you can't eliminate certain subject
matters.
You just can't because the human
language is very nuance.
There's a lot of shit going on in every
single interaction that you have.
We're humor could potentially be crafted
from,
it can be taken into a whole wide
variety of different ways,
and I like all of those ways.
I like people saying fucked up shit.
They don't really mean.
Sure.
I think this something funny and Tracy
Morgan saying if a photo,
most of them was good,
I still be a little new glue and it's
ridiculous.
It's ludicrous,
right?
It's not real.
Of course he wouldn't do that.
Of course it would be,
you know,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
The idea that it's like,
I do a joke in my act like guess what,
Johnny Cash didn't really shoot a man in
Reno just to watch him die either.
Maybe it's,
I don't think he did.
He might more likely that he did it then
Tracy Morgan would stab his son.
Yeah.
So bid johnny,
johnny,
Johnny Cash probably should have said I
took some pills and fell asleep on the
tour bus.
I'd be more accurate.
Longest boxing match ever.
Let's find out.
Match ever boiled typing
was the longest boxing match in history.
Oh my God,
a boxing match land.
It lasted seven hours.
How many,
if I can do the math man,
what the fuck is that?
Is that real?
Okay.
Oh my God.
Listen to this.
The longest boxing match ever took place
in New Orleans on April six of 1893 the
matches between Andy Bowen and Jack
Burke,
both of whom claimed the lightweight
title after the reigning Champ,
Jack McCall,
full all of fee,
all a fee check my call if he retired,
the winner of this take all purse was
set at $2,500 and in order to decide who
is really the new champion,
the match was set to fought to a finish.
They fought to a finish.
I like that.
All through the contest,
fighters went at each other aggressively
pounding each other with their gloves,
inflicting and sustaining tremendous
punishment.
That red,
like someone wrote it with their pants
off.
That red light is a vigorous.
They masturbating oiled up and shaved
and ah,
yet three minute rounds wore off.
Oh my God.
They went to 111 rounds.
Both fighters,
dazed and weary gave up.
And did not come out of their corner
pools.
Well,
you can't fight on hundred and 12th
around how to be one guy telling him
just get up rocky and your win.
Guinness Guinness says it's 276 rounds
in 1825 that's the English people.
Why might we heard it much longer than
that?
Our endurance is superior.
We've proper boxing training.
That sounded more South African,
so maybe they're right,
man.
I Dunno.
Whoever fought over a hundred rounds is
the craziest fucking human being that's
ever lived.
That fight was only four and a half
hours.
Oh,
that's weird.
What do they have a 32nd rounds?
Hmm.
It doesn't even make sense.
I can't even do the math.
All right.
I'm not going to try 2,500 bucks.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
For the welter,
the welterweight championship of the
world are lightweight rather these days.
That's a good question.
It's a very good question.
I've been to be like 1 million bucks.
Yeah.
Is that weird?
Like when when you hear about like
economies imploding and then all of a
sudden like a loaf of bread is worth $1
million,
like how the fuck,
what does that even mean?
Yeah.
I don't even understand that people have
billions of dollars.
How does that number even a real number
and can I,
how do you pull out $1 billion in cash?
Me?
See?
Yeah.
At a certain point in time you have to
admit the hack the game.
Okay.
You acting game somehow,
dude,
how'd you get $10 billion?
I don't understand.
When you know you gotta like Bill Gates,
you have submarine and inside your giant
bear,
you know like,
Hey,
what happened here?
What exactly did you do?
Where are you getting all that money?
This is,
this isn't fair.
We have escape pause in your house to
jettison you to the middle of the
fucking ocean whenever it fucking danger
shows up.
Yeah.
You have a constant team of security
detail around you that's like having a
bank,
you know around you all the time.
Bill Gates is worth what?
100 billion or something crazy like
that.
It would have.
It was the whole Jv,
him dropping $40,000 he shouldn't pick
it up kind of thing.
Yeah,
that's what they say.
It's like if he drops $40,000 it's worth
more of his time to keep moving forward
than it is to turn around and pick it
up.
He just,
what?
What happened was he just didn't turn
around and pickup the bonus.
I just got almost for,
for bludgeoning and other man for 15
minutes.
He,
if he dropped that,
he wouldn't pick it up,
son.
Oh Shit.
Itunes or recording to server the fuck
outta here.
Server.